so I've recently come across this
small-time twitch streamer who wanted to
raise five grand in order to fly to the
Philippines so he could meet his dad for
the first time in his life he thought
he'd eventually hit his goal but it
might take some time but then literally
this week as he was signing off stream
and saying goodbye to everybody
a mysterious donator by the name of
fatty melon dropped a nearly $5,000
donation essentially funding his entire
trip and while this is a pretty
heartwarming story by itself what's even
crazier is that our mysterious donator
has been quietly dropping dozens of
life-changing donations for a while now
okay so I first learned about our
mysterious donator through a streamer
named King Tubby that's the guy I
mentioned off the top and up until he
turned eighteen duh bead really didn't
know much about his dad I did I've never
met him never to know of my father when
I turned 18 my mom kind of like showed
me like his his profile on Facebook and
stuff and like my siblings over there or
one of my brothers and like gave me the
option if I wanted to contact him I I
knew about him my whole life I just said
never she never gave me like his real
name when I turned 18 she like gave me
pretty much all of his info that she had
um so then this summer was just a really
hard summer and it's something about
struggled with his just not having that
like father figure in my life yeah so I
decided like beginning of fall late
summer I was like hey I think I'm ready
can we try and reached out to somebody
he eventually got in touch with his dad
over social media and then with the help
of a friend they started this fundraiser
and tried to raise money through twitch
donations he kicked off those
fundraising efforts on November 19th and
it's here where we meet the dude named
Fatih melody we raised like 200 some
dollars before any of that happened
Fatih mellon who donated the rest of it
gave me five hundred dollars because I
had told him in like a another person's
chat beforehand so right off the bat
it's pretty easy to see that this dude
who calls himself Fatih melon is
probably a pretty generous person debbie
is streaming on Twitch and one of those
group
dreams where everybody has like a
separate panel and at this point he's
raised about $1,200 and he needs about
two grand for the plane tickets dubby
told me that his plan was to raise the
to brand buy the tickets for February
and then between now and then raise
enough money for hotels food and a
camera so that he could document the
whole trip but as he's literally signing
off to go watch a friend's basketball
game this crazy moment happens what
happened that was a sudden rush somebody
fatty melon showed up again and dropped
nearly 4,700 dollars in donations
it's an insane moment and it's a
reminder to me that twitch could be a
great place for the little guy something
that I think gets lost when we're
constantly covering twitches fuck-ups
now these donations change Debbie's life
but his story is only one small part of
a much larger story that I want to share
with you because as it turns out fatty
melon has been doing this for months I
reached out to him and well he doesn't
feel like talking on the record we've
been DMing back and forth quite a bit
and he's cool with me sharing some of
his story fatty melon is something of a
philanthropist somebody who donates
money regularly because they can after
he was introduced to twitch a year ago
by a friend melon started donating to
small streamers whenever he could and
he's become something of a mysterious
twitch legend what no that's not real is
that is that is that real a 3300 $33.33
own Asian what the flowers
fati Miller whose fatty melon what three
thousand three hundred and thirty three
dollars and 33 cents
what holy [ __ ] who's that who in Scotty
melon he donated over twenty five
hundred dollars to her streamer named
misbehaving to help her fund a new PC um
guys it's daddy still in here it's Bobby
still in here it's bad he's still in
here
come here you
[Music]
and he apparently gifted over 1,100 subs
to this dude who fell the [ __ ] out of
his chair now in talking with fatty
melon he estimates that he's given over
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
between gifted subs and straight
donations in the last four months to be
very clear I reached out to him about
this story he's not some dude looking
for attention or clout he just happens
to be in a position to give back to
people in need and honestly he donates
some times just so people do some funny
[ __ ] on stream like repeat fatty melon
for ten hours straight
fatty melon fatty melon fatty melon
fatty melon fatty melon fatty melon
that's melon fatty melon fatty melon
fatty melon or to watch a streamer
completely obliterated melon with
various household objects how I've
talked a lot of [ __ ] about twitch and
they often deserve it but to me this
story gets at the heart of what twitch
is truly capable of in their best
moments I mean just think about it for a
second right melon could have taken all
of that money and donated it to a big
charity which theoretically would have
gone to a good cause but we don't get to
see the immediate impact we don't get to
see how important it is to give back to
people when they actually need it twitch
at its best provides that immediacy it
allows us to literally see how important
it is to give back in a positive way and
honestly you don't even need to give
back financially to see that positive
change these are tears of happiness by
the way I'm just thinking taking back
all the people about all the people I've
met
you know while starting this journey off
and this [ __ ] closet so
you guys changed my life
single-handedly and I appreciate you
guys and honestly I have no idea who
this fatty melon is like his social
media presence is literally a photo of a
melon and there is no like verifiable
photos of him anywhere there are two
other fatty melon stories that I want to
share with you before I leave
meet mu he's a DJ who regularly streams
on Twitch and he's also a bit of a
heavier guy who recently decided that he
wants to live a healthier lifestyle so
someone in moves chat recently asked him
how much it would take for him to eat a
salad on stream and Moo jokingly
responded but thousand dollars fatty
melon just happened to be in Moo's
twitch chat when he joked about this and
he reached out to the stream and said
hey dude check your PayPal account I
don't remember exactly or if maybe just
mini hit fraud is up in general someone
he has asked me on camera he's like hey
you know how much would it be for you to
salad because I hate salad and like
jokingly said on camera a thousand
dollars bad and email and happened to be
there that shrimp watching us do this I
went off camera and chucked because he
said check my makeup and lo and behold
the man actually sent me $1000 and
here's the original clip when it
happened live on Twitch move
are you gonna make me cry stuff like my
aunt Fatima one ended up donating
another 666 dollars to Moo and said that
if he was serious about getting healthy
he would fund a meal plan for him to
help him stay on track the last guy I
want to tell you about is a small
streamer named bear Wang but I'm gonna
use his first name Dan now Dan is one of
the first people fatty melon donated to
now at the time Dan was streaming a ton
of Fortnight while melon says that he
doesn't really care about fortnight he
was watching dan and loved his overall
attitude so he donated $1,000 to the
small streamer one of the people I met
through twitch she goes to me I was you
know super grateful and just you know
saying my thanks and welcoming all the
new people in chat and fatty was one of
them fatty melon was one of them I start
up another game and then close to the
beginning of the game he donates $500 so
I turned my cam on and I thanked fatty
melon 500 like that's crazy
thank you so much and then it literally
has him like thanking him he donates
another five hun
now unfortunately we don't have the
original clip but once Dan realized what
was happening he actually broke down on
stream and explained why he was
streaming in the first place
we were pretty behind on mortgage loans
so the end product would have been that
basically we would just have to you know
a clean up shop and move somewhere else
take a loss on the house my mom wasn't
working at the time my dad wasn't
working either so it was it really was a
tough spot
and after Dan explained that he was
streaming so he could bank a bunch of
money to help out his mom Patty Mellon
was blown away and donated another ten
grand you don't make it five hundred
three more times to make the total of
2.5 k I'm trying to keep calm I'm trying
to you know still be on my game was
still streaming you know so
I'm playing I'm playing I'm playing and
then he donates another 2.5 to make the
total 5 yeah and then he donated another
2.5 into them another 2.5 to make the
total 10 I remember how I just remember
being so like happy I gave my mom half
of it I gave my mom 5k just to just pay
off a month or two of the mortgage loans
and yeah it's being super proud of
myself and happy ain't grateful
obviously the fatty melon that I could
give my mom this check for 5k you know
so that's it guys we found this random
dude who's donated over 250 grand to
small streamers Twitch did something
positive for once
happy [ __ ] holidays well this is my
thought right like so I get it at one
point in history some dude boiled down a
bunch of [ __ ] oats and managed to get
whiskey sure I understand that but like
who [ __ ] decided it was a good idea
to take heavy cream raw eggs blend that
[ __ ] together stick it in a carton and
sell it for [ __ ] $4 a leader who
wants it and who makes it nobody wants
that [ __ ] it's not good yeah and then
there's some booze in it